a Google Scholar search for misogyny
yielded 114
000 results whereas a search for
misunder yielded only 2 340. people are
not studying or really concerned about
anti-male bias especially from women
there's actually an even better Google
result that I think I didn't find until
after I wrote that paper but I Google
imaged men are stronger than women which
is just empirically correct but of the
like 41st images that popped up on the
screen I think one of them was yes
confirming that and then there were like
two neutral and all the raster images of
women being stronger than men so women
running faster than men women like
raising a man over her head the best
presentation I think of speed and power
the disparity between men and women is
the women's 100 meter record so the
women's hundred meter record that hasn't
been beaten in a want to say 20 or 30
years is held by 100 or 200 under 18
males like high school level males hit
that female number